des jeunes mieux formés grâce à la
révolution numérique c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait montrer les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine lors de
cette première fête du numérique il faut
que à tous les endroits des territoires
départementaux
chaque élève a et la même chance de
réussir et l'espace numérique
c'est un outil formidable pour justement
aboutir à cette égalité des chances
par exemple à l'égard des décrocheurs on
arrive à repérer leurs carences et de
leur construire une orientation qui va
leur permettre de combler les trous
qu'ils peuvent avoir plusieurs projets
pédagogiques ont fait l'objet de
conférences et de partage d'expériences
concours robotique ou encore exposition
de maquettes sur le collège de demain
l'occasion également de présenter un
nouvel établissement qui ouvrira ses
portes en 2021 à mantes la jolie et dans
lequel le numérique aura toute sa place
qu'est ce qu'un collège de demain
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait besoin pour
étudier le mieux possible et en fonction
de ça on a adapté tous les locaux aux
besoins des usagers
ce rendez vous d'aujourd'hui il illustre
finalement
l'investissement que chacun y met celui
des collectivités locales celui de
l'état mais il illustre aussi la réponse
qu'on espère vivent aux besoins de nos
enseignants et de nos de nos élèves
au cours de cette journée le département
des yvelines et le rectorat ont
également signé trois conventions en
faveur de l'inclusion
elle prévoit notamment le prêt d'outils
numériques pour les collégiens en
situation de handicap